et je me tourne vers vous à présent et
hélène frade vous avez lu la presse
internationale est évidemment cette
intervention russe et est largement
commenté ce matin la russie attaque
poutine mais le monde en garde hebeisen
promet de lui faire rendre des comptes
titres ce matin de new york times qui
cite la déclaration du président
américain joe biden le président poutine
a choisi une guerre prémédité qui
entraînera des pertes de vies humaines
et des souffrances humaines
catastrophique je le cite des semaines
de diplomatie intense et l'adoption des
sanctions occidentales n'ont pas réussi
à dissuader poutine qui a amassé entre
150 mille et deux cent mille soldats le
long des frontières l'ukrainienne
annonce de moscow times qui cite lui
évidemment le discours du patron du
kremlin quelques minutes seulement avant
cette intervention la situation nous
oblige à prendre des mesures décisives
et rapide a justifié le président russe
en ajoutant que moscou procéderait ge le
site à la démilitarisation et à la
dénazification de l'ukraine selon le
journal d'opposition novaïa gazeta les
des métadonnées de cette vidéo la vidéo
de cette déclaration de guerre
montrerait que celle ci aura été
enregistré lundi soir à 19 heures heure
de moscou c'est à dire en même temps que
le long discours prononcé par vladimir
poutine annonçant la reconnaissance des
séparatistes du donbass le secrétaire
général de l'onu lui implore moscou de
cesser son attaque au nom de l'humanité
je sit in à l'occasion de l'ouverture
d'une réunion de l'assemblée générale
des nations unies antonio goûter rsa
prévenu hier que le monde faisait face
je le cite à un moment de péril une
déclaration voilà une du journal
britannique the independent zent côté
ukrainien le sait le gouvernement a
décrété l'état d'urgence dans tout le
pays a annoncé la mobilisation des
réservistes au moment même où vladimir
poutine convoite ici à la une du
guardian participait lui à une cérémonie
de dépôt de gerbe sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu à l'occasion de la journée du
défenseur de la patrie une image
évidemment extrêmement symbolique qui
montre à quel point bladimir poutine a
parfaitement orchestré au millimètre
près les événements de ces dernières
quelles sont les réactions dans la
presse ukrainienne le rédacteur en chef
du site d'infos sensor qui dit se
trouvait près de dounia ski à l'est de
l'ukraine enjoint ses compatriotes à ne
pas avoir peur à l'image du président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky con qu'on a
entendu à l'instant l'ukraine va gagner
veut croire youri bluetooth off qui
évoque l'un des moments les plus sombres
de l'histoire de l'ukraine j'entends la
guerre écrit-il mais nous sommes unis
par une confiance commune
l'ukraine s'est forgé dans la lutte pour
la liberté l'ukraine deviendra plus
forte dans la lutte pour la liberté
ont-ils à la presse russe ce matin
hélène alors c'est lise bastien qui est
proche du kremlin ça martèle à l'image
du kremlin que l'intervention de l'armée
russe fait suite à l'aggravation de la
situation militaire dans les territoires
séparatistes pro-russes du dombass dont
les chefs se seraient tournés vers
moscou pour repousser l'agression je
cite du gouvernement ukrainien non
l'armée russe n'a pas effectué de tirs
de missile aérien ou d'artillerie sur
les villes d'ukraine assène le quotidien
en citant le ministère de la défense de
la fédération de russie le cren retard
mais tout ce qu'ils peuvent tenir une
arme à la main c'est à dire contre les
séparatistes
sans surprise le site svoboda nappe vos
bottes n'est qu'après sa part dont
reprend tel quel un mot pour mot la
propagande du kremlin qui justifie cette
intervention par la menace supposée
d'une attaque massive de l'ukraine
contre les séparatistes
le site nationaliste reprend lui aussi
les communiqués du ministère de la
défense russe qui parle de frappe
militaire de haute précision et promet
que personne ne va bombarder les villes
c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
victimes civiles ces civils que le
président ukrainien a appelé ce matin à
l'instant à défendre leur patrie merci
beaucoup hélène frade pour